GOVERNMENT, MEMBERS OF THE
PARLIAMENT, ALL DISTINGUISHED
GUESTS, FRIENDS.
BEFORE I BEGIN, I WOULD LIKE YOU
TO UNDERSTAND MY FEELINGS AND
FEELINGS OF ALL UKRAINIANS, AS
FAR AS IT IS POSSIBLE, OUR
FEELINGS OVER THE LAST 20 DAYS,
20 DAYS, OUR FULL SCALE
AGGRESSION OF RUSSIAN FEDERATION
AFTER EIGHT YEARS OF FIGHTING IN
THE DONBAS REGION, CAN YOU ONLY
IMAGINE THAT ON THE 4:00 A.M.,
EACH OF YOU, YOU START HEARING
BOMB EXPLOSIONS, SEVERE
EXPLOSIONS, CAN YOU IMAGINE
HEARING YOU, YOUR CHILDREN, HEAR
ALL OF THESE SEVERE EXPLOSIONS,
BOMBING OF AIRPORT, BOMBING OF
TENS OF OTHER CITIES, CAN YOU
IMAGINE THAT?
THROUGH THE MISSILES BEING,
FALLING DOWN, AND YOUR CHILDREN
ASKING YOU, WHAT HAPPENED AND
WHICH INFRASTRUCTURE HAS BEEN
BOMBED AND DESTROYED BY RUSSIAN
FEDERATION?
AND YOU KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE
ALREADY DIED, CAN YOU ONLY
IMAGINE WHAT WORDS, HOW CAN YOU
EXPLAIN TO YOUR CHILDREN THAT
YOU JUST, FULL SCALE AGGRESSION
JUST HAPPENED IN YOUR COUNTRY.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS WAR TO
ALIENATE YOUR STATE, YOUR
COUNTRY.
YOU KNOW THAT THIS IS THE WAR TO
SUBJUGATE THE PEOPLE AND ON THE
SECOND DAY, YOU RECEIVE
NOTIFICATIONS OF HUGE QUALMS OF
MILITARY EQUIPMENT ARE ENTERING
YOUR COUNTRY, CROSSING THE
BORDER, ENTERING SMALL CITIES,
THEY ARE GIVING SIEGE,
ENCIRCLING CITIES AND THEY START
TO SHELL NEIGHBORHOODS, THEY
BOMB SCHOOL BUILDINGS, THEY
DESTROYED KINDERGARTEN
FACILITIES, LIKE IN OUR CITY, IN
THE CITIES.
IMAGINE SOMEONE TAKING SIEGE,
LAYING SIEGE, CAN YOU JUST
IMAGINE FOR A SECOND, AND ALL OF
THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE LEFT IN
SUCH CITY AND THAT IS EXACTLY
THE SITUATION THE CITY OF
MARIUPOL IS LEFT WITH RIGHT NOW,
AND WITHOUT MEANS OF
COMMUNICATING, ALMOST WITHOUT
FOOD, WITHOUT WATER.
SEEKING SHELTERS IN BOMB
SHELTERS.
CAN YOU IMAGINE THAT EVERY DAY,
YOU RECEIVE MEMORANDUMS AROUND
THE NUMBER OF CASUALTIES,
INCLUDING WOMEN AND CHILDREN?
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THE BOMBINGS,
CURRENTLY, WE HAVE 97 CHILDREN
THAT DIED DURING THIS WAR.
CAN YOU IMAGINE, IF IT WAS HIT
BY RUSSIAN BOMBS.
OF COURSE, I DON'T WISH THIS ON
ANYONE BUT THIS IS THE REALITY
IN WHICH WE LIVE, WE HAVE COME
TO CONTEMPLATE AND SEE WHERE THE
NEXT BOMBING WILL TAKE PLACE.
WE HAVE FREEDOM SQUARE IN THE
CITY, THE BOMBING HERE, THE
PLACE WHERE VICTIMS OF HOLOCAUST
WERE BURIED AND IT HAS BEEN
BOMBED BY THE RUSSIANS.
IMAGINE THAT CANADIAN FACILITIES
HAVE BEEN BOMBED SIMILARLY AS
OUR BUILDINGS AND PLACES ARE
BEING BOMBED.
THE NUMBER OF FAMILIES HAVE
DIED.
EVERY NIGHT IS A HORRIBLE NIGHT.
RUSSIANS ARE SHELLING FROM ALL
KINDS OF ARTILLERY, FROM TANKS.
THEY'RE HITTING CIVILIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE, THEY HIT
BUILDINGS.
CAN YOU IMAGINE THERE IS A FIRE
STARTING AT THE NUCLEAR POWER
PLANT AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED IN OUR COUNTRY.
EACH CITY, THEY ARE MARCHING
THROUGH, THEY'RE TAKING DOWN
UKRAINIAN FLAGS.
CAN YOU IMAGINE SOMEONE TAKING
DOWN YOUR CANADIAN FLAGS IN
MONTREAL AND NOW THE CANADIAN
CITIES?
I KNOW YOU SUPPORT UKRAINE.
WE'VE BEEN FRIENDS WITH YOU,
JUSTIN, BUT I WOULD LIKE YOU TO
UNDERSTAND AND TO FEEL THIS,
WHAT WE FEEL EVERY DAY.
WE WANT TO LIVE AND WE WANT TO
BE VICTORIOUS.
WE WANT TO PREVAIL FOR THE SAKE
OF LIFE.
CAN YOU IMAGINE WHEN YOU CALLED
YOUR FRIENDS, YOUR FRIENDLY
NATION AND YOU ASK, PLEASE CLOSE
THE SKY, CLOSE THE AIRSPACE,
PLEASE STOP THE BOMBING.
HOW MANY MORE MISSILES HAVE TO
FALL ON OUR CITIES UNTIL YOU
MAKE THIS HAPPEN?
AND THEY EXPRESS THEIR DEEP
CONCERNS ABOUT THE SITUATION.
WHEN WE TALKED WITH OUR
PARTNERS, THEY SAID, PLEASE,
HOLD ON, HOLD ON A LITTLE
LONGER.
SOME PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO TALK
ABOUT THE WORD ESCALATION, AND
AT THE SAME TIME, IN RESPONSE TO
OUR ASPIRATION TO BECOME MEMBERS
OF NATO, WE ALSO DO NOT HEAR A
CLEAR ANSWER.
SOMETIMES WE DON'T SEE OBVIOUS
THINGS.
IT'S DIRE STRAITS BUT IT ALSO
ALLOWED US TO SEE WHO OUR REAL
FRIENDS ARE OVER THE LAST 20
DAYS AND AS WELL, EIGHT PREVIOUS
YEARS.
I AM SURE THAT YOU'VE BEEN ABLE
TO SEE CLEARLY WHAT'S GOING ON.
I AM ADDRESSING ALL OF YOU.
CANADA HAS ALWAYS BEEN STEADFAST
IN THEIR SUPPORT, BEEN A
RELIABLE PARTNER TO UKRAINE AND
UKRAINIANS AND I AM SURE THIS
WILL CONTINUE.
YOU'VE OFFERED YOUR HELP, YOUR
ASSISTANCE, OUR EARLIEST
REQUEST, YOU SUPPLY US WITH THE
MILITARY ASSISTANCE WITH
HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE, YOU
IMPOSE SEVERE SANCTIONS, SERIOUS
SANCTIONS.
AT THE SAME TIME, WE SEE THAT
UNFORTUNATELY, THEY DID NOT
BRING THE END TO THE WAR.
YOU CAN SEE THAT OUR CITIES LIKE
KHARKIV, MARIUPOL AND MANY OTHER
CITIES ARE NOT PROTECTED JUST
LIKE YOUR CITIES ARE PROTECTED.
EDMONTON, VANCOUVER.
YOU CAN SEE THAT KYIV IS BEING
SHELLED AND BOMBED, EVEN THE
C
CITY.
IT USED TO BE WE WERE A PEACEFUL
COUNTRY, PEACEFUL CITIES AND NOW
THEY'RE BEING CONSTANTLY
BOMBARDED.
BASICALLY WHAT I'M TRYING TO
SAY, WE ALL NEED TO DO, YOU ALL
NEED TO DO MORE TO STOP RUSSIA,
TO PROTECT UKRAINE AND BY DOING
THAT, TO PROTECT EUROPE FROM
RUSSIAN THREAT.
THEY'RE DESTROYING EVERYTHING.
MEMORIAL COMPLEXES, SCHOOLS,
HOSPITALS.
HOUSING COMPLEX.
THEY ALREADY KILLED 97 UKRAINIAN
CHILDREN.
WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR MUCH.
WE'RE ASKING FOR JUSTICE.
FOR REAL SUPPORT, WHICH WILL
HELP US TO PREVAIL TO DEFEND, TO
SAVE LIFE, ALL OF THE WORLD.
CANADA IS LEADING IN THESE
EFFORTS, AND I AM HOPING OTHER
COUNTRIES WHO FOLLOW THE SAME
SUIT WILL ASK FOR MORE
LEADERSHIP AND PLEASE TAKE MORE,
A GREATER PART IN THESE EFFORTS,
JUSTIN AND ALL OF OUR FRIENDS OF
UKRAINE.
ALL FRIENDS OF THE TRUTH.
PLEASE UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS FOR US TO CLOSE OUR
AIRSPACE FROM RUSSIAN MISSILES
AND RUSSIAN AIRCRAFT.
I HOPE YOU CAN UNDERSTAND, I
HOPE YOU CAN INCREASE YOUR
EFFORTS, YOU CAN INCREASE
SANCTIONS SO THEY DO NOT FUND
THEIR WAR EFFORT.
COMMERCIAL NOT WORKING IN
RUSSIA, PROBABLY YOU KNOW BETTER
THAN MANY IN ANY OTHER COUNTRIES
THAT THIS ATTACK ON UKRAINE,
IT'S THEIR ATTEMPT FOR UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE AND THERE IS NOTHING ELSE
TO IT.
THIS IS THEIR MAIN OBJECTIVE.
IT'S ACTUALLY THE WAR AGAINST
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE, AND IT'S
ATTEMPT TO DESTROY EVERYTHING WE
AS UKRAINIANS DO.
IT'S AN ATTEMPT TO DESTROY OUR
FUTURE, TO DESTROY OUR NATION,
OUR CHARACTER.
YOU CANADIANS, YOU KNOW VERY
WELL ALL THIS.
THAT'S WHY I'M ASKING YOU,
PLEASE DO NOT STOP IN YOUR
EFFORTS.
PLEASE EXPAND YOUR EFFORTS TO
BRING BACK PEACE IN OUR PEACEFUL
COUNTRY.
I BELIEVE AND I KNOW THAT YOU
CAN DO IT.
WE ARE PART OF THE ANTI-WAR
COALITION AND JOINTLY ENSURE THE
RESULT.
I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO ASK OUR
UKRAINIAN DIASPORA IN CANADA,
THIS IS A HISTORICAL MOMENT AND
WE NEED YOUR SUPPORT, YOUR
PRACTICAL SUPPORT.
AND WE HOPE WITH YOUR PRACTICAL
STEPS, YOU WILL SHOW THAT YOU'RE
PART OF THE MORE UKRAINIAN
HISTORY.
PLEA